hello everybody we had a lot of
monsters and obstacles to deal with
but with the help of ben and danny
hopefully
the problems are solved and
i am live and about we double checked
that
on the ipad 2 or i see an ad so that's
usually a good
thing well two of it's not as good but
all right i guess we are yes
hi you see i love the technology but at
the same time i'm just like
i needed to be over the board so i can
just
go on the screen and say okay this is it
this is that move the king up move the
queen down voila
all right i'm glad to know this
is working so um i was
uh looking at some of my well
old games baby dorsa games well actually
not two baby dorsa this is
still um this was 2014
so it makes me feel old but um i was
actually 2014 i was just
sixteen years old six years old so not
that old but
um still i was trying to find some games
with good stories
for uh one of the panels that i was
doing for
uh usgs jennifer shahadi right before
this class
so um that
is why i took this memory lane
the took this drive down memory lane i
guess that's the right way to say it
anyways um in this game this was a very
a nice game for me because this was the
first tournament
that i was like super close to scoring
my first wgm arm
and i fell short by few
rating points performance wise but it
was a very interesting
tournament it was in uae in sharjah
man when i was in iran i used to go to
uae like every two months three months
like play a few tournaments win some
money come back
feel nice ah that's one of the things i
do miss
about middle east i was just
really um there were a lot of good
quality tournaments in uae anyways
this was a um women's specified um
women tournament i think it was called
like
sharjah the capital of islamic center
something like that they had a very nice
chess club so
i remember it was formed like a castle i
really like that
anyways um so this game was one of the
last rounds i believe this was um
two rounds before the the uh this was
like
this was a nine round tournament this
was round seven i was playing
against um if i'm not mistaken yes
abdullah she was higher rated than me by
about 100 something points
she is a very strong azerbaijani
um at that point she wasn't the one i am
but i
think she got her woman jean ever since
i mean it's been six years man
i've updated my titles by a few
anyways so let me show you this game um
for those of you who have watched other
videos of mine
you already know that i am
um kind of good with
um preparation so i
had prepared against her but i was
pretty sure she was gonna go for bishop
e5
and i think i wanted to play yanish for
those of you who
are fan of playing ganesh i would
definitely
recommend that the video i did on yanish
when i played the
jean abdemalik in 2015 ward junior
championship
ah poor girl had a seven out of seven
strike and
faced me and well no more strike
anyways um i think this is what i was
planning to play against her and i was
quite nervous because
i had some new ideas new
ideas for myself and this knight c3 and
i wasn't
completely sure if they were the
best ones to go for so she played d4 and
i was like
okay d4 uh scotch and still not my
favorite to play against
especially because i played with white
after bishops if i was like oh
thank you all the big guys up there
bishop c4 yes
and after bishop c4 i
actually do know this line very well so
if you're playing against me
and one of the players viewers um feel
free to give it a try but
be prepared all right so bishop c5
castle d6 uh it's just kind of critical
not to rush into knight f6 because light
f6 now they're e5s or bishop g5
a lot of different things for white to
um for black to deal with so d6
stop all of this shebang with e5 none of
these
stuff anymore and now as uh
black if you give me two more moves i'm
going to put this bishop on g4
this knight on f6 maybe bring my knight
on e5
go after d's and everything is under
control
so white's gotta play c3
still bishop g4 uh if you do take here
from what i remember just knight takes
and it's so good black is a pawn up
i can just play knight f6 and i want a
castle and
everything seems to be going alright
so um that is why
the best move here is queen b3
going after f7 so now um even though
i am a little rushing because i gotta
talk a little faster in the remainder of
the time
but i would like to ask your opinion on
what do you want to do here as black
you do have limited choices you can
either defend f7
and deal with the problems on d4 and b7
or you could take on f3 so what do you
think you should do
should you take on f3 and after like
bishop takes f7
king f8 is that something you would want
to enter
or well basically how do you wanna give
the pawn that you are up right now back
okay interesting there is a queen d7
suggestion
um i am a little
um not sure about queen d7
because um queen d7
what if just take on d4
and you can't really take back because
just take
take and then b7 falls and also bishop
b5 is coming up you can't really play c6
so you got to play like rook c8 bishop
goes to a6
and this is uh unpleasant
to say the least you move the roof there
should be five and loopsie-doopsy
so let me go back to back here so
that is kind of why we are going to look
deeper into bishop takes f3 so after
bishop takes
f3 um if white simply takes back
all right great now i have knight e5
defending
this guy attacking your guy everything
is working out
great so that is why um
white has to be very careful and take on
f7
first and then take this so now in this
position how do you think we should
follow
yeah bishop f3 idea is definitely
worth thinking about but another way to
think about it is in this position
yes your king is uncastled but
the problem is for white is that this
bishop here
had a lot of issues like you give me few
moves i'm gonna
start developing attacking your bishop i
could even try to
bring my queen athletes this way and
your king
isn't safe either so it is a very
complicated position yes
um so
another idea to think about yes my type
6 is definitely doable
bishop d5 i think is something to
consider
uh because now knight e5 is popping up
what about something with uh maybe
maybe just bishop let's go to c4 now we
can take on one take on
here but what if i do knight a5
i think this is also interesting
for both sides
um the problem is that eventually i do
have to take this d
take c3 and if the knight takes now the
d5 score is also an issue
so that's something that it's it would
be great if we could
take care of immediately that's why we
could
start thinking about taking a c3 first
because
now if you take with the knight
now um this is bad why why why how do
you think
as black we can use this
it is very complex you got that right
so what do you think we should do now
there is a big problem with knight takes
c3 exactly thank you everybody knight d4
and um you are in
big pickle basically you can't you
cannot
hold um your position um
you play something like queen c4 i'm
gonna take over here and then i'm gonna
play knight t5 you
play by queen d5 but can i ask let's
just do knight f6 huh i guess that's
good enough exactly and i want to do
this again as soon as you play queen c4
so you are losing your bishop on f7
so in the other line that
we saw after um not taking let's say
after knight
f6 the issue was that eventually i had
to take
and he would take with the knight and
the knight was getting in the game
right so that is why um
now we shouldn't just play knight f6 we
should
use this opportunity to take that pawn
now
if y takes with the knight we had the
knight d4 that was just mentioned
but what if y takes with the pawn what
do you think we should do now no more
knight d4 but we still have knight e5
so what do you guys think about that
1895 is good
um knight h6 now
um i mean it's possible but
why not play at e5 because knight e5 you
would be
attacking f3 and f7
so this is much more pleasant than any
other move
to be completely honest you move the
bishop i'm gonna pick that up
then i'll give you a check over there
then i'll develop my knight
i mean it's still pretty complicated um
but black definitely
um is putting a very good fight
and also having one more pawn helps
so yeah
um yeah i think this is an interesting
position
but i do think that after
so let me go back here
as black we decide to use this chance
and
take on c3 when he can't take back with
the knights
so what do you think is the best thing
for black for whites to do
keep in mind that we just talked about
white can't take back with the knight
because we go
here we take that and the knight e5's
that we did the queen would be on c4 so
it would
this bishop on f7 is the problem so
but here is white to move so what do you
think white
can try and do to deal with this bishop
on f7
so right now white to move what do you
think we should do
yeah exactly why should get rid of this
bishop it doesn't look very
um smart at the first glance because
you're like whoa this bishop is already
here
um dealing with the king so why would we
take on f8
but you're correct i think you can come
because you're going to avoid this
temple
of knight e5 so take
we're going to take that back now white
gets to take knight takes c3
so how is this any different can i still
do knight d4
is 94 still strong
what do you guys think about this
position
all right so you i see you guys still
like knight d4
and heads up my cat is very
vocal and he's giving me some
meowing stuff so be careful with those
uh
yeah he's made some lovely appearances
on twitch channel
i guess he wants to conquer youtube as
well
from the looks of it all right yeah i
think knight e5 and knight d4 are the
best ones but knight d4
is more natural because you're also
wearing a trap what if
queen takes b7 now how do you guys want
to deal with this
you could take on f3 but uh oh
i see there's jump coming up oh my god
kitty
you gotta go not the right time for an
appearance
all right bye bye kitty
good boy okay
he graced us with his presence so we are
all blessed
we can win this game
yep basically all right um
so what now what do you guys want to do
in this position
yep exactly rook b8 first after rook b8
queen has to go to d5 basically now we
get the queen out
we don't need to rush into taking on f3
we can't first get the queen out
no way for white to actually defend this
if you play like king g2
i still have jeep oops g5 and g4
and that is also a huge issue
so
yeah queen b7 is a mistake
let me go back now so after
take take um
knight d4 queen d1 is the best move
now what do you think we should do here
how can we uh can we still try with the
same g5 idea
should we try and create more
should we bring more pieces before we
start g5 stuff like that
curious to see so yes we definitely
should be considering g5
but we should yeah i hear queen f6 first
we are preparing for g5 um the
one question that we could we should
definitely have an answer for is what if
knight goes to d5 what's now what do you
want to do with your queen
because um if white didn't
play knight d5 if white looks played
king g2
now we can simply play g5 or even queen
g6 i kind of like queen g6 queen h5 idea
first let's get this queen in a very
dominant position and if you play king
g2 now i can simply play g5
yeah i really like this even more so
um let's see
what else can we go
so the only thing that we should
actually
consider like be worried about
is knight d5 so what do you want to do
after knight d5
do you want to do queen g6 are you gonna
do like are you gonna try and get your
queen to h5
or uh just keep your queen on the
um on the f file
um question about f4 i
kind of just after i try to call this
i'll play queen h4
then try for g5
maybe queen h3 i think i like this idea
um how far i i get that after f4 g5 you
want to play f5
maybe but then i have g4 and i can start
pushing this
and go after the g3 with the bishop on
c5
yeah f4 i think g5 is also interesting
all right so after knight d5 what do you
guys want to do take on f3
um you could but if you take knight
takes f3
what are you gonna do after king g2 give
this check potentially
but the king comes to h3
and then what do you want to do with
your queen go back to d8
i don't think this is a very um ha
long castle yeah a good one i wish i
could do long castle now
actually not now my queen is under
attack but yeah
so let me uh i don't think knight f3 is
a blunder but i definitely
do think that knight f3 uh is not the
most accurate one
after knight these five i think win f7
is just good enough
well careful not to take on f3 with the
queen because
after exchange uh you're still c7 is a
problem
so you also you do give this check king
goes to
let's say just h3 you move the sniper a
little around
now i can just take here and then attack
give you this um
nice fork so that's why we just play
queen episode just
keep it all um normal
after bishop e3 now what do you think we
should do
should we take on f3 now is it time
keep in mind that king g2 is also
possible but not the
not the um nothing that we couldn't
handle because we still have c6
and then we give this check and we still
do this queen f6
so we could still try with g5 later on
but from what i remember um i was kind
of ready for
a perpetual like this like if you play
kg to king h1
i think that was something that i had
looked into that potentially if this
happens
and also i just know that papa blanco
was in a hollywood production movie but
definitely should be i think that's a
good idea i would watch that movie
i was i didn't really feel the the
fisher movie that they made what was
that palm sacrifice
back in 2014-15
i didn't feel bad what i thought i
thought they made
fisher look weak fisher was very strong
very
strong-minded person so i'm not
entirely sure how i felt about that one
i mean
definitely could be better anyways so
king g2 would be interesting but what if
bishop e3 now how do you wanna
do do you think it's the time to take on
f3
well we could bring the rocks into games
but
um why not nights knight xf3
don't you guys like eating ponds
what's wrong with knight acceptory why
can't we eat it now
the problem previously was we couldn't
just take it like that because the
knight on d5 was attacking
our queen on f6
so why not take
well hold on hold on rookie one you
still have issues with a tie to f3
so after knight f3 if king goes to h1
you have no problem you're just gonna
play g5 you're gonna do g4 and voila
so the best thing for whites is to play
king g2
now we can think about c6 or knight h4
because c6 we're not technically
defending the lines but we are
going as our opponents might so doable
but
i played knight h4 because i wanted to
keep as many
pieces as i could king g3 now what do
you think we should do
heads up king h3 was the best move can't
someone tell me why how why these two
moves are different
like why king history is better than
king g3
um queen h5 uh careful
whoops no the thing is we do c6
take take over there and
after queen exchange um this
is a drawing game so this is what
white should have tried to get into um
whereas after king g3 c6
um wasn't the best move but after
i think here he should have taken on h4
and after take
take queen f3 queen f5 some exchanges
like this
um black is still doing slightly better
because of the weak bond and the pass
pawn
or later on the palm majority but um
the thing is that here back
in this position
c6 wasn't the most accurate one because
now i have the chance to actually play
g5
but i slightly chickened out because i
wasn't sure what i'm going to do
if let's say take and f4
that slightly worried me but i simply
had knight f5 check
and i did not see that one in the game
because
okay i hope that explained
how hard this was for me to figure out
knight f5 wasn't a natural move to me
and i just didn't see it
but now in this position black is
actually pretty winning
i'm gonna pick this up soon and i'm
gonna attack your queen unless you move
your queen which i'll still pick this up
next move i'm gonna take that the rooks
are active the queen is active this pawn
is kind of covering my king
so it was kind of a it would have been a
good deal
um another move that i was
unsure what i would do after was f4
but even after f4 i was like
still like what am i supposed to do if i
take it
king takes on h4 i take that then
there's queenish five what if just
knight takes on e3 but i think knight d3
i thought about queen f6 so that's not a
big deal because there's queen
six so what a queen h5 trying to cover
up the king
and now basically only move
anybody want to take a stab at it or
shot at it i don't know why those are
the expressions but
anybody wants to take a chance not like
take a chance better
then take a stab take a shot or such
things like that
anyways um yeah rick g6
good one daruslav uh yeah our g6
and the ifcoin tries to go to f5 you
exchange that
that's perfectly fine and you try to
bring your other rook
and i looked into this end game quite a
lot after the game because i wanted to
be
thorough on what i missed and this end
game is actually quite pleasant for
black
as you guys can see the king is in the
center but uh still dangerous
uh my bishop is very pleasant position
this pawn could
become a monster soon
all right let me go back to
something else that i was thinking about
and i wasn't sure how i would respond in
the game
so c6 is what i played but after g5
another move that i wasn't sure is what
is b4 so after b4 i played bishop b6
a4 queen e8 sorry i didn't play bishop
b6 that's something that i
potentially could have played but
it just i just couldn't find the right
way to break through and i was just like
right i know there should be something
but
where is it where is it and i
um ended up chickening out and not
playing this
g5 so up at c6
and we ended up just
getting into this position check
i had to play queen e7 and
finally how what do you guys think about
this end game
is it good is it bad you want to be
white you want to be black
yeah i think something like um
being able to figure out all of the
moves after g5 was a little bit
unrealistic at least over the board
so all right anyways yeah black does
look uh
quite better but after
[Music]
king e7 knight f5 would have been the
best move to try and exchange the
knights like that
but he went with knight she went with my
g4
i got some nice h5
and rook f8 see going after this
cute mate over here and
we got into this position so
rook and game two pawns up shouldn't be
that hard right but she put up a really
good fight
um i thought maybe rook d6 then rookie 7
but still this endgame should be winning
enough
yeah the the dynamic yep i agree
so i'm going to go a little fast right
now because
i'm just basically trying to improve my
position i'm trying to push some ponds
i'm trying to
make white give me some weaknesses some
nice targets
oh please take that rook all right now
rooks exchange let's bring the king
trying to bring the king
and saving all of my pawns
uh but it is pretty worse i agree but it
still needs
i still need to get my my pieces
out so that's what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to not
rush it and i'm still trying to get my
pieces to get into where they need to go
here was another interesting um
position i thought about king d6 but
king d6 i wasn't entirely sure if i'm
comfortable giving this pawn up
so simple king c8 now i might want to
go around like this
he going to shoot king e4 with rook d5
let's just keep everything super duper
chill
and here i could have just brought the
king
but i really wanted to just
go with some font to be completely
honest with you
if you play king f5 go after this pawn
whoops
i have rook four and i'll pick all of
these guys up
so she went king e5 rick d3 he hit one
pawn i eat bunch of puns
sounded like a good deal to me let's eat
that guy
let's defend here uh careful if we took
over here there
there could have been some king b6 ideas
but anyways this is super duper winning
now
um just let's just try to get the king
out lovely let's eat that pawn too
and you guys can't imagine the rest
actually
not much left let me just show you up
until how it's
wins um it was kind of interesting
because if i played a4
then um he wants to she could play
something like king's a8 and try for
some stimulate
so i thought that was an interesting
last try
but she just simply went so i mean i
just simply played through e4 and then i
got the con out no no need to rush it
and finally won this game
yeah it was a very interesting game
especially because
um she was high rated i kind of got an
interesting position out of the opening
but it's still had a lot of ups and
downs
i think g5 would have made the game much
more beautiful
compared to c6
but g5 was just i don't know if i would
play g5 right now
if like having um matured
and live nhs and um
having more experience under my belt
as expression says i still don't know if
i would have played g5 today
so i'm not too sad about not playing g5
but i think this is a very good game i
kind of wish
i had more time to ask you guys some
questions about what
you wanted to do so um have a lot of
tactical
points so if you want to
go back and just pause and think about
other moves
i would encourage you to do so and
without further talks
i am going to um say goodbye to you for
now
and give you to my coach alejandra
ramirez i think that's happening on
twitch
i think so um feel free to check him out
tell him i said hi
and yeah this was fun thank you for
sticking around with some of the issues
that we have
glad you stayed alright i will